we begin with breaking news russia's
foreign minister sergey lang
lavrov says he will ask 10 u.s diplomats
to leave
as his country responds in kind for u.s
expulsions and sanctions against the
kremlin
and he says russia is looking at painful
measures aimed at u.s businesses
president joe biden announced an array
of sanctions on thursday for what he
says is
russia's election meddling and cyber
attacks
let's go live to our correspondent
bernard smith in moscow bernard this
uh very much a case of tit for tat
talk us through in more detail what
russia has announced today
yes we're just getting some more clarity
on what sergey lavrov said in the in the
last half hour
or so as well as expelling 10
u.s diplomats they're also going to
sanction eight
u.s administration officials their names
will be revealed later that sort of
matches
the individuals that the us the number
of individuals
sanctioned by the us russia also says
he's going to close u.s
foundations and ngos because they are
interfering
in russian affairs we haven't been given
the names as yet of the
foundations and ngos specifically that
russia is referring to
they're going to stop the u.s hiring
russians and
other third country nationals from
working in its missions here
in moscow that is because russia says in
our missions in the u.s
we only hire russians now for the u.s
here that could affect everything from
drivers and cleaners to analysts
and other individuals who may be working
in the us diplomatic
uh missions here in russia so that could
make life particularly difficult for the
americans here
um and they've also threatened
to go a bit further lavrov said that
there are 450 people
working in the u.s missions in the in
russia
and 450 russians in the u.s but 150 of
those lavrov says work in the un mission
so he says if the u.s goes further in
sanctions against russia we will ask the
u.s to take another 150 people out
and lastly he suggested lavrov
suggested that the u.s ambassador here
john sullivan
should go back to the u.s for
consultations this is this is not
expelling the us ambassador but is
suggesting he go back to the us
to discuss with his superiors what's
happening that is because lavrov says
their ambassador to washington dc is
currently here
in moscow okay many thanks for that
bernard smith
talking to us there in moscow